ready stop yelling at me
you need to go inside
are you ready for the big reveal we
finally learned
what happened between jihoon and
drusilla that had him on the ground
bawling what happened he let's go with
dracula
lets her run all the way in the street i
yell at him to get her
and he yells at me in front of my mom to
not yell at him
while he's letting her run that way when
he knows that she can get hit by a car
but he's not
more concerned that i'm yelling him yep
that's it don't get me wrong i am glad
driscilla did not get harmed
but the way they reacted was as if she
did
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
on the latest episode of the other way
the challenges that come with parenthood
hit a new level for some of the couples
and for jihoon in particular his failure
to meet that challenge
resulted in a face-off with devin's mom
keep yelling angry mad i say stop
yelling at me
that was mom alicia explosion
after the incident ji hoon stayed
outside to
comment nerves and devin took drusilla
into the house
but she shortly came back out to
confront him
he's proven time and time again that he
is not ready for a family and
i just feel like i made a huge mistake
you just like yelling me
i very fast vlog
you were more focused
on your pride instead of protecting
drusilla
i get both sides i'm not a mother yet
but i can only
imagine the fear you would feel in that
moment
watching your child run towards the
street but
at the same time it is not all jihoon's
fault
it's not drusilla didn't listen i'm not
sure
why exactly but that's definitely
something they can work on
listening skills chinese
nothing is jihoon's fault it's always
everyone else's fault
so i have no sympathy for him when he
cries in front of me
well whether it was sympathy or not a
few minutes later
she forgave him
i will be a better dad because i really
love you guys
[Music]
no i don't want free i want family
only
my honest heart okay didn't do that
that went pretty smooth but then jihoon
felt like it was necessary to
apologize to devin's mom and uh
just take a look at what happened i'm
really sorry mom
i'm just i'm really
bouncy susie saying so sorry is gonna be
great when
i'm scraping priscilla off the damn
street
just get just dude
your tears mean nothing to me
drusilla is everything to me
as expected devin's mom was definitely
harder to get through to
than devin after ji hoon pleaded his
case
she left him with these words gee who
and i honest to god
it's not my decision it's devin's
decision
i know you know you're saying
i understood but if you kill my
granddaughter
i'm going to kill you
all right let's move on to our final
must-see moment
binham took ariella who is jewish to his
orthodox church
to discuss baptizing their baby my
parents
are also not of the same religion my
father is jewish and my
mother is roman catholic honestly
i always felt really uncomfortable with
the idea of christianity
because i don't believe in hell it's
just so
awful to me i don't think that it's
something that we should be teaching our
son about
well ariela is about to get even more
uncomfortable
because binium was told by the priests
that in order for their son to get
baptized
she has to become a christian
we need to both be the same religion
yeah and he says
you have to barters too sorry
this isn't gonna work
[Music]
my first thought is no way
i've already given up so much and
sacrificed so much to be with baby i
feel like he's just asking too much with
this
but um
based off of what he just said about
heaven and how ariella feels about hell
it's very obvious that these two have a
long
road ahead of them even longer than we
expected
i feel really sad because i can't help
but feel like
i might not be the right person for him
but i love him and i have no idea how
we're gonna get over this how we're
gonna
compromise on such an important topic
the entire situation hits ariella hard
next week as her mom prepares to head
back
to the states if i'm gonna miss you
remember
don't make me cry all of a sudden i feel
really overwhelmed with the fact that
i'm here to stay
i'm not looking forward to being alone
with you
i'm not happy about it
ariela hey it's so true
the choices you make determine
everything
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
to stay updated on all the latest news
from our guilty pleasure
i'll see you next time
you